this Christmas tree lecture where the
general idea is to uh uh to tell you
about the coolest thing I learned about
trees during the year uh trees are
somehow uh
you know the center of computer science
and uh so uh there's there's generally
much more to talk about in any
particular year but uh today instead of
talking about the coolest thing I
learned this year I'm going to talk
about something I learned several years
ago because it's just so beautiful and I
didn't get to talk about it at the time
uh since uh I I was in Sweden so you
know so this is the 15th annual except
that I I missed once or twice being up
being out of the country so
um now before I warm up
um though um
I let me talk about Christmas because uh
you know here's the time for for uh for
giving and I have some great gifts to
recommend to uh to the audience so so
for example one one one one
definite thing to ask for from your
loved one uh
well can you anyway
this book uh came out 15 years ago
um and you know so you might say it's an
old book but it's new because it came
out in paperback for the first time now
and and not only that but it's been
totally you know brought up to date
because it it actually talks about the
internet in a modern way and things like
that so you know so so it's been it and
it doesn't have a single known mistake
in it which means that uh okay anyway
it's uh I think they did a nice job
putting it out in paperback and uh it's
got stuff about trees and it's why I
mentioned it uh spanning trees uh and uh
and you know
tree structures used all the way through
so it um uh you know in case uh in case
somebody doesn't know what to give you
this is you know hint now on the other
hand even even better
is this one
um generating all trees see that now
this this book actually inside of here
um
contains almost everything that was in
my previous Christmas tree lectures I
mean you know there's lots of uh there's
all kinds of stuff in in here uh look at
all the trees here you see
you're seeing freaky anyway there's
beautiful pictures uh and uh lattices of
trees that was one of my one of the
subjects we talked about uh you know
drawing drawing beautiful trees okay and
and even if you don't like trees you can
go on to the next section with about the
history of commentatoric combinatorial
generation and it has wonderful pictures
in there too so uh now this this one I
looked on Amazon today and it's it's
selling for 16.99 uh plus shipping I
guess
um and it's um it's number 618
000 on there on their list
even though it's got uh it's got five
star rating
but but not only that uh you can if you
look on Amazon and you and you don't
want to buy from them and you want to
buy from some place where they some of
the other places that deliver somebody
is selling it for
140.85 plus 399 shipping so just imagine
uh if anybody uh
uh you know once there must be a really
spiffy copy I don't know how they got
for 140 anyway this is uh uh so so
there's all kind of stuff about trees in
here and um uh and I and uh
uh uh I I I have to I have to give you
one caution though uh a year from now
I'm going to be holding up uh a hard a
hardback version which costs a lot more
than 16.99 which is going to have uh uh
five times as much stuffing or six times
as much stuff as this but including this
but I'm hoping somebody will read this
uh you know uh carefully in between
because there's awful lot of fine print
here that that that has uh uh subtleties
uh and I want to get it right uh before
it goes out in hardback so you know so I
want to know about that in the next six
months or so now one other thing before
I finish this
um
uh in case you don't learn anything else
uh this hour I had to tell you something
that you can use on your Christmas cards
and that is this
2009 or I should have written this last
is equal to one half
plus three
times
4 plus
5 times the quantity six times seven
plus eight times nine
now there's a fact that I bet you you've
never seen before uh
and if you want to know how to get this
it there's an exercise in here you use
trees to do it and and in fact this is
the only way to take you know to insert
signs in the sequence one two three four
five six seven eight nine including one
division you're allowed plus minus times
uh subtraction you know plus minus times
and divide and and this is the only way
to put a division in there and still
make it work okay so there you are
a uh you know put it on your Christmas
cards or whatever okay now for for uh
for presence I'm also given giving away
a whole bunch of stuff
um uh for example uh you see 2009
is not only a a a year but it's an
awesome year because in Roman numerals
it's mmix and that's the that's the
number of my of my computer that you
know that that I designed for the for
the 21st for the for the third uh
Millennium and um
and uh so uh uh you know now if you want
a book about mmix I have it here uh uh
look at this uh it's still shrink wrap
uh uh and uh and I have an extra copy
I'm giving it away uh the guy from
Boston gets First Choice all these other
books I put up here uh uh you know uh
please take them away I have X I've
spares of all this uh I also have a book
about mmix uh uh explaining it uh for
for Polish speakers
um
and uh uh if you uh
uh if you can't read polish maybe you
like the Hungarian version uh okay now
so now
uh
there's also uh uh however uh
let's see so here's the uh
I want to put them out here so you can
easily see all right so a bunch of other
stuff here you see here's the
here's the here's the one about trees uh
that I showed you before
um you know except it's in Hungarian no
wait this is number
this is number two what do I want this
one yeah this is the this is the tree
you know uh oh no
four three four four aha
trees here we go okay
yeah
um so if you want to see the uh you know
that same thing I showed you before but
this but in Hungarian uh here it is for
free and uh and then I got a bunch of
other Hungarian impulsions and stuff
here and Japanese
uh
uh let's see yeah
the the tree one isn't translated into
Japanese and then I got a whole book
here volume one of the art of computer
programming
uh and this is in check
so uh there you are and I hope uh you
know somebody who actually can can can
speak the language uh uh picks them up
but otherwise why not look you can
always learn all right so
now
today spanning trees and aspects this is
a this is such a beautiful subject uh I
I I I I I I can't resist you know uh
going into teaching mode and saying here
is one of the most fun things to teach
that I know uh it's it's something that
to add to it to everybody's toolkit uh
the ideas are not uh a lot of them are I
don't don't need higher math but higher
math doesn't hurt for once you get
started uh and so I'm gonna I'm trying
to get you started on this idea a very
beautiful subject of uh of Interest I
think to anybody who Whoever has to work
with with graphs and almost every
application of computer to discrete
things works with graphs so so so I I
hope you I hope you enjoy uh uh learning
learning about this uh if you don't
already know it
um now so the whole thing starts out
with um
uh
with me getting getting my my notes
together
um
and uh
it starts out with something that we
call the Matrix tree theorem
and the Matrix tree theorem is is I I
think it was my second or third
Christmas tree lecture you know years
and years ago uh a very very well known
important theorem but I'm going to
remind everybody uh about it and and
tell a little more and it's a it's a
it's a very simple idea
um and I'm going to for I'm going to
draw a a a simple directed graph it
applies to any directed graph but I'm
going to draw one that has three
vertices and I'm going to mention three
uh six arcs on it there's a one two
three and
um uh so Arc a goes from one to two Arc
B goes two to three Arc C goes three to
one and then I'm going to have arcs
going the other way I'm going to have
going backwards this is going to be
capital a
and and capital B and capital c going
this way
no
capital B
is gonna emanate from from Two and
capital c is going to emanate from three
oh all right uh so now now I I I write
down the following Matrix
um
uh in in row one I take a look at the
things that come out of vertex one
and I and I I I put a plus capital A
those are the two things coming out of
vertex one uh a goes to two so I put a
minus a here uh capital A goes to three
so I put a minus capital A here I write
down the whole Matrix and then you see
what the what the general idea is and
we'll give more examples in a minute
um
when here we are um
so in e in in on the diagonal I put the
I list all the arcs going out of um uh
you know of one two or three uh but in
in a position i j where where I and J
are unequal I put the negative of Arc
that goes from I to J
all right now
um interesting thing about this um
this matrix by the way this is
this graph is G this Matrix is called C
of g capital c of G and uh and uh
traditionally commentarius I call it the
laplacian Matrix of a directed graph not
because LaPlace ever
ever saw this Matrix in his life uh or
or maybe not any Matrix in his life but
but because he worked on some
differential equations that uh that
suggested to somebody some theories that
eventually suggested to somebody this
Matrix and so it's it's called The
laplacian Matrix now
uh let's take a look at at the uh well
the deterrent of this Matrix is is zero
that's that's pretty obvious because
every row sums to zero
um so so the determinant has to be you
know the sum of the three columns is
zero so so let me so determinant of a
matrix is zero if there's linear uh
dependence
between the columns but or or rows or
anything but uh
uh if if we if we look Instead at the
cofactors of the Matrix which means that
you that you take that you throw out any
one row in any one column and and you
write down the determinant of the rest
uh then you get something interesting
and so here I show you the example take
the determinant of B plus b
minus B minus cap C and C plus C okay so
so uh now uh
I'm not going to use high power Matrix
theory in this talk but I am going to
use determinants if determinants scare
you uh too bad but just enjoy the jokes
but but it I'm not going to use high
power determinant Theory either so the
determinant of a two by two Matrix uh
you know that's B if this this minus
this this so b c plus little B Big C
plus Big B little C plus Big B
Big C that's this times this and now I
subtract the product of these guys and
so that's minus little B Big C and so
these are canceling
and I get three terms left over and now
let's relate them to the arcs over here
uh Little B is the uh is the thing going
from two down to three and little C is
the thing going from
you know one going from
going from three to one uh Big B was the
thing going this way
um
and little C was this one again
um right and then uh Big B and Big C
are these are this
now can anybody figure out what's
what's special about this combinations
of arcs
take a look at the one that canceled by
the way the the little B and Big C
notice what happened there
those formed a loop
okay so somehow when you get so what so
one of the one of the things that
happens when you expand the determinant
of this thing wherever you have a loop
uh it seems to it seems to cancel out
okay so so these are called the oriented
trees that go to vertex one
okay spanning trees
so an oriented spanning tree of a
directed graph is the uh with a certain
root says you take any vertex other than
that root and there's and there's one
one thing going out of that vertex
uh uh you know so from two you have to
have one thing coming out exactly one
from from three you have to have one
thing coming out exactly one you follow
these and eventually they take you to
like to the other vertex which is the
root
so this doesn't look that much of like a
tree if well I could draw it like this
and so on but you know that's the that's
the idea of a of an oriented tree uh all
of the uh uh everything has a parent uh
and and you go to the parent and then
the to the parent to the to the
grandparent so until you finally get to
to the root which doesn't have any
successor so so every every uh that's
the idea of an of a of an oriented
spanning tree
now uh in general this is this is what
the Matrix tree theorem tells you that
is if you take if you write down this
Matrix you know if you you take some
directed graph uh and and you uh uh if
you want to you can give labels to the
you know you know to the to the arcs and
you you could write this thing down and
then you and then you uh you you throw
out uh uh everything in row uh uh I and
column I and and you take the
determinant of what's left uh and uh
that gives you all of the oriented
spanning trees of the uh of that graph
well let now let's take let's take
another example
um
so uh this time I'll have four vertices
but I'm not going to have all the pi I'm
not going to give all the possible edges
um
so I'll go from one to two and call that
a I'll go from three to two and call
that B I didn't choose these these
labels any in any particular way two to
four I'll call it e what a c c is going
to go from three to four and D is going
to go from four to three
um and F is going to go from four to one
that's enough okay so now now let's
let's find let's find uh The laplacian
Matrix of this guy
uh so from from one the only thing
coming out of one goes to two right so
so I write that a here
and minus a 0 0.
uh out of two what do you call somebody
call it out
what
zero zero
zero zero minus E very good okay now how
about the next row
B plus no sorry zero zero minus B minus
b b plus C B plus C minus C minus C all
right and now so okay you get the idea
of Laplace and uh and now
um
uh you might wonder uh I told you what
what happens if I if I strike out uh uh
all rows uh I mean row I and column I
but what if I strike out row I and
column J for something else well then
you get you know you get a minor of this
Matrix uh uh and uh uh what you can work
it out and here's here's what it looks
like
um
uh so on the diagonal you get these uh
uh we'll check them you get the oriented
uh uh you get the oriented uh uh
Hispanic trees of of that directed graph
uh you see what's happening everywhere
else it's a checkerboard pattern you've
got mine you get plus minus plus minus
minus plus minus plus looks like a
checkerboard so you so so everything in
the in in the first row is the same
except that uh alternating signs in the
second row third row like and so on the
on the diagonal you get the the thing I
told you about so that's what happens if
you happen to uh you know to to take
your your your laplasting and and
evaluate any one of the any one of the
determinants and uh so for example here
from three it looked like there's only
one way one spanning uh directed
spanning tree uh oriented spanning tree
uh uh that that goes to to three in here
right
um uh because from one the only place to
go is is to two and from two the only
place to go is to four
so if I if I've taken one to two and two
to four and now I I've got to get to
three somehow so for nope you know I
can't send four back to one
because that would get me a loop so 4
has to go to three and so so that's the
that's the only solution a
uh a uh e
um
uh four to three is D so a d e is the
only is the only solution in that and
that's what we had on the diagonal there
uh on on the other hand you can work it
out I'll I'll write it out so you if you
want to check it
at your leisure bef plus CEF are the are
the ones that lead to lead to a
uh the ones that lead to B are ABD plus
a d b f plus ACF there's three ways to
get the two and down here we have a b e
plus a c e
uh I want to mention a famous unsolved
problem and uh if anybody wants to solve
this one uh I might even look at it and
sign your thesis but but you have to
hurry because I'm getting I'm going to
work on something else before long but
the the unsolved problem is this uh take
any any uh directed graph and any vertex
in the graph and and and figure out how
to list all of the directed spanning
trees in such a way that to get from one
to the next you're only taking out one
Arc and putting in one other Arc
for for example uh uh you know b e f c e
f well you change B to C all right ABD
ABF change D to F right a b f a c f
change B to C right
but ABD doesn't go directly to ACF so so
so so no two two oriented Spanish trees
are are next to each other if they have
all but one Arc in common
and uh the question is is it always
possible to to go through all of those
oriented spanning trees uh uh in in a
hamiltonian path in some something
that's next to each other uh at every
step and and you hit them all okay uh
it it uh it's a great problem nope
obviously nobody knows of any examples
where you can't do it uh
uh but nobody's been able to figure out
a systematic proof that you always can
do it
all right now
um of course I don't I didn't have to
form this matrix by writing down these
letters here and calculating the
determined cell if it's a real big graph
uh that's a lot of algebra and
cancellation and everything uh uh it
might take take a long time but instead
I could replace all of these guys by one
and and you know and then you know I
have one minus one zero zero zero one
zero minus one so minus one two minus
one minus one zero minus one two right
and and then I would get two three one
two uh on the diagonal and that would
tell me uh just how many there are it
doesn't tell me what they are but it
tells me how many there are right
because because everything evaluates to
you know to to the sum of the of the
thing so here we got a good way to count
how many there are uh uh uh you know and
this could be a big Matrix but it's
pretty easy to evaluate uh uh
determinants that that's an efficient
that's an efficient solved thing
now um
let me let me uh
harp a little bit more about this Matrix
though and that is let's find its
characteristic polynomial now now every
Matrix has a characteristic polynomial
which is uh uh uh
defined uh to be equal to uh uh
um
Chi of X or characteristic polynomial of
x uh and I Define it the way I learned
it although Mathematica does it
backwards uh uh x times the identity
Matrix minus the The Matrix which we're
trying to take the characteristic
polynomial of so for example C of G
uh the characteristic polynomial of of
CFG is is this and it turns out if you
if if you if if you take this Matrix and
you can you work out it's it's
characteristic polynomial so you
calculate the determinant here
um and you know keep track of powers of
X
there's five people standing in the back
and uh I encourage you to actually come
up in front uh because it's more
comfortable and it makes me more
comfortable and uh you know and and you
might if you want to get one of these
free books at the end you're closer
oh
yeah thanks so so here's what here's
what it turns out to be you can you can
evaluate it and you get X forth uh
that's easy that's on the diagonal uh uh
and then if you want uh in other words I
have it's the determinant of this Matrix
x minus a
a zero zero x minus E zero e and so on x
minus B minus C
you get the idea here
um so I take the determinant four by
four determiner that's and here I get x
minus X cubed times a plus b plus C plus
d plus e plus f
um and then plus x squared I'll write it
down a minute minus x times a b d plus a
b f plus a
c e and so on now see if anybody can
figure out what what are the things that
I'm writing down here
at the bottom
okay uh you said spanning trees
and uh why do you say that
because
uh what happened what's the code yeah I
might as well put the put the Matrix X
here you'll see what's happening
um
f
uh x minus D minus F and this is 0 D
here okay so so if I if I'm going to get
a a term with One X in it that means
that I pick one of the x's on the
diagonal and the coefficient and then
and then the way determinants work then
then the the coefficient of that X is
going to be the the determinant of
everything else
and so if I do that for each you know
for for this x this x this thing this x
I get here it's the sum of all of the
it's the sum of all of these guys that I
had on the diagonal there
so that's the is so so this is the set
of all the um uh the directed spanning
trees uh for all possible routes
uh you know some of them had Route One
some of them had root two some had root
three some had root four in fact uh uh
if I you know it's two plus three plus
one plus two so there's eight eight of
these oriented spanning trees uh uh but
but uh it's you know three of them have
have two as the root uh now uh but but
can anybody figure out oh by the way
what's this coefficient here x cubed
that's the that's just a list of all the
edges right okay but now what's this
what what am I what's this thing in the
middle here what's the coefficient of x
squared
excuse me
uh something with two edges that's good
they certainly all have two edges
and and and and now it's not every
possible combination of two edges though
because if you notice uh uh there's six
edges here and there are uh 15 possible
combinations of of six edges taken two
at a time uh but there's only 12
one two three four five six seven eight
and eleven twelve yeah some some of
these aren't aren't listed here
without Loops that's part of it yeah but
there's but but take a look and tell
somebody tell me why BC is not in this
list
yeah huh Can we see the graph again oh
okay didn't you remember the graph
yeah okay there you go
um oh PC is not just through a path
connected what's wrong with BC
it's not connected in that definition
it's not the directed path it's not a
directed yeah B has has two things
coming out of it
we gotta choose two vertices and and
something coming up and uh and not make
any loops that's known as an oriented
Forest an oriented Forest is like an
oriented tree but it's it's it's got
more than one tree
so so this is the this is the way to
take you know to to make all oriented
forests uh with two arcs uh out of this
graph and and in general this is what's
going to happen in the characteristic
polynomial that you get out of any uh
laplacian uh the coefficient of x is
going to be all of the uh uh oriented
forests that that are actually trees uh
the coefficient x squared are the ones
that are going to have ornith for us to
have two that are made out of two trees
and and so on three trees
four trees you can't have four trees on
uh uh uh uh you can I mean the empty
graph is an oriented Forest that had uh
on four trees but you can't have
um uh the case of zero uh uh zero trees
um in an oriented Forest so that's why
this is always a multiple of X here all
right so that's that's the that's that
the property of the Matrix tree theorem
that's that's not very often mentioned
that everybody usually only talks about
uh uh the the the thing about them
taking the minor of this Matrix but but
the characteristic polynomial tells you
more too all right now
um
now we now let's start uh let's start
using some some interesting graphs but
but uh I'll show you a bunch more
um and uh uh one of the first that you
might
that you might try is um uh is is is uh
uh
us unfortunate well let's go to four
elements let's stay with four elements
for for a while but now I've been
talking about directed graphs and really
undirected graphs um our uh our uh
uh probably a rising
um in in most applications or at least
most most things are known about under
at the grass and uh and uh as time goes
on we're learning more and more about
the that the directed graphs uh have a
lot of great properties too but usually
you have an underactive graph which is
really in in most cases
um the same as having a directed graph
but every every Edge in the ordinary
graph is actually an arc going going
this way and an arc going the other way
so we write it only once
and but but really it stands for
you know
um
two arcs so each Edge is two arcs
um okay so what's the uh uh what's the
laplacian here here I'm only going to
count how many things go out and not and
and I'm not going to gonna give names to
these arcs uh so how many things are uh
uh touch one uh they're you know also so
it's it's like this right uh what one
goes to two not to three and and it goes
to four
2 goes to one actually uh it's
symmetrical in a in an undirected graph
this this Matrix is always symmetrical
about the diagonal okay uh so 2 goes to
one and to three not the four
um and then three goes to four and you
know coming back here and four so this
is the uh this is the Matrix this this
particular graph um it you know it's a
square but uh uh it has it has two two
main names one is that the you could
call it the the two dimensional
Cube
um uh and P2 Square P2 is is a nice way
to write it uh we'll we'll generalize
that later but it's also it's also
called uh uh the four cycle C4
and this is what it has uh as it's as
it's uh laplacian Matrix and the
characteristic polynomial is X to the
fourth
minus eight x cubed plus 20 x squared
minus 16x
um and uh the reason is that um if if we
want to look at this directed wise uh uh
let me show you the um
of the spanning trees that uh that are
rooted at one
okay what I have to do is I have to put
in I have to I have to put an arrow in
each one and so that everything except
one has has has an arrow coming out of
it
and one is the root
all right now
um
uh these are the oriented spanning trees
of this graph
that have that are rooted at one
now now
um if I
but I first wrote on you know I I first
drew it unrooted
um
uh I mean unoriented and and the nice
thing about this that this graph is uh I
slowly just take a spanning tree of an
undirected graph
um and and so I just that just means I
choose edges I choose n minus one edges
that connect up the graph it means that
that there's no cycles and uh you know
this is the the definition of a free
Tree in general uh a spanning tree uh a
graph with n vertices you choose n minus
one edges in such a way that it's all
connected up
and or in such a way there's no Cycles
so those two two conditions are
equivalent to each other and those are
the spanning trees of the graph and they
are
extremely important in solving
electrical circuits and all kind of
stuff
now after I've after I've drawn it
though if I decide that one of the
vertices is going to be the root
then I just draw arrows so that
everything is shows the arrow the way to
get uh uh to to the destination
all right so for example if I wanted if
I wanted two to be the root
um
and this will work
for any any spec any spanning tree of
the graph uh now if I say say put arrows
on here uh so that becomes a directed
spanning tree uh what do you do well
well from every vertex other than two
there's a unique way to get to two and
so you just say which way you go to it
right so so so for example
um I would do this because I have
wherever you are there's there's one way
to get the two and that that defines
zero so so this uh this connects up the
undirected graph uh idea to the directed
graph Theory and and and the underactive
graph is is simpler uh
because the Matrix is is a symmetrical
Matrix and so uh a lot more things are
true about symmetrical matrices uh okay
now but you'll notice then that that the
every every
spanning tree occurs uh n times if
there's n vertices one for each root
okay so that's why you got 16 here
uh there are four spanning trees of this
graph but each one occurs four times
okay so so the coefficient of x is
always n times the total number of
spanning trees and that's a crucial a
crucial thing because because one of the
things we want to learn here is count
how many spanning trees are there in a
graph
and uh it's always it's always the
coefficient of x uh divided by n
uh now by the way uh what about the
forests
um uh the spanning the spanning force
that uh uh and and and there are um
um the following spanning forests
um
they're they're
um I'm going to draw
just just a few of them
but um you'll see what I'm what I mean
in a minute here Arrow going this way in
this way I have air going this way in
this way and an arrow going this way and
down
but you can't have arrows going away and
uh to the right and Away down that
that's not allowed every every vertex
has to have have either one successor or
no successor
and and two of the vertices are roots
so here here I get up up or up down or
down up or down down so so uh uh
that I'm trying to explain why there's
20 here
um
uh
the
um
let's see there are four
four times
there there are four cases like this
yeah so there's four times three is
twelve and there are two cases like this
uh you know these two guys are these two
guys and so that's four that's four
times two so so the you know twelve and
eight is twenty so so that's why I got
20 guys here and and okay so anyway
that's the character it's a polynomial
and by the way the characteristic
polynomial factors x x minus two x minus
two x minus four
okay
so that's the
that's the um uh uh the two-dimensional
Cube a graph actually that and I'll do
one more for one more four vertex graph
before we're done that's that's K4
that's the the complete graph fund for
everything is connected to everything
else and uh the Matrix looks like this
uh it's got threes everything everybody
has three
um uh things and um
uh and and minus one everywhere else and
uh if you find if you want to look at
the characteristic polynomial uh it
turns out to be x to the fourth minus
12x cubed plus 48 x
squared minus 64 x which factors into x
times x minus four x minus four x minus
four
believe me all right so that's
you know you can work it out just just
write down the Matrix calculate the
determinant and so on I'm going to give
you a couple more examples and then
we're going to see why explanation why
this all fits together and and and uh
and and makes to makes really beautiful
patterns beautiful Theory and uh uh
I think the best one to go to next is
the three-dimensional
that a three-dimensional Cube which is
what a cube really is so notation is P2
Square P2 Square P2
and it looks like this
um sort of
um
I don't know there are people who draw
much better cubes than I but this will
be good enough for today so I let's call
this one two
three four
five six seven eight for example and the
Matrix looks like this every vertex has
degree three and uh
uh one is connected to two four and five
and and uh so I work it out here until
you just get the idea that two is
connected here this one goes to here
this one will go here
um
and uh they seem to be connected to the
guys on their left and right so it's
like that
um minus one minus one minus one minus
one minus one we'll put a minus one over
here and then
over here just got to be symmetrical so
this is O minus one okay so this is a
eight by eight Matrix uh this is
I'm not going to have courage to do any
anything bigger today but we're going to
have Theory so that we can so that all
of a sudden we we don't have to write
down all this stuff we can actually
calculate without a lot of extra work
um
okay here's the
uh
Matrix then and uh what is it what do we
get uh as a as a typical um
spanning tree for example
so that means choose seven edges
um uh that connect everything up and one
of the typical ones might be uh say this
and okay for example
one two three four five six seven okay
so you might say how many spanning trees
are there of this Cube
and uh
uh well uh
that's I write down the characteristic
polynomial in factored form
is x times x minus 2 x minus two x minus
two
x minus four x minus 4 x minus 4. this
is like high school high school
everything factors
you get a polynomial okay now so so if
you work it out this is equal to x to
the eighth uh you know minus something
or other and so on and then then you get
a minus uh uh
3072 X at the end here so how many
spanning trees are there
yeah 307 to
over 8 is 384. so it turns out there are
384 spanning trees of the uh you know of
the of the cube
all right
um
a few quick graphs on five on five
vertices so that you can see that this
Theory doesn't only work for the graphs
you've seen before this is a this is a
kind of a weird graph this happens to be
there
um oh but before I before I tell you
this
I better tell you explain the title in
my talk now the talk was called spanning
trees and aspects
and uh
I've got to tell you now that the
aspects
of the cube
are
zero two two two four four four and six
now every graph on N vertices
had 10 aspects
and
they are the roots of the characteristic
polynomial of the laplacian okay so now
if it's if it's an underacted graph this
Matrix is symmetric Matrix and uh it's
well known that the that the
characteristic polynomial the symmetric
Matrix always has real roots
and always always has non-negative real
Roots it's it's a semi-definite matrix
because it's diagonally dominant
um so uh
uh there's always these n n roots of the
characteristic polynomial and we cut and
uh uh I'm calling them the aspects now
the reason is that I saw I've seen them
arise in many many problems and I
decided that there ought to be a there
ought to be a special name for for these
guys sometimes you know now some people
say they're the laplacian eigenvalues of
the of the graph that's a big mouthful
it's too long to say laplacian
eigenvalue is one two three four five
six seven eight nine
um nine syllables for such an important
concept right so I got to have a short
name
for them so I um I I decided I I got out
rosace thesaurus about 10 years ago and
I'm saying what what's the best you know
what's a word that hasn't been taken yet
about graphs uh that's still pretty
short and and memorable and that would
convey uh the the the essence of of the
of what these eight numbers are for for
an eight vertex graph and my answer was
I'm going to call them the quanta of the
graph
uh so I so I said these were the quanta
of this graph all right well then I then
I happened to be on an outing with
Michael Dube who's one of the greatest
Experts of this whole theory of the uh
of the uh
characteristic values of graphs and
and he also has written some books about
tech that's how come I how come I met
him but but we were on this excursion
and I'm saying oh Michael let's call him
quanta
and and he didn't like it so so then we
we spent the the rest of the day
brainstorming and and uh we both uh we
both liked aspects all right and and and
you know so we wrote some letters back
and forth uh later on and uh and uh you
know we still came to the conclusion we
do like aspects now of course we we
can't push this uh I mean I I I'm not
like the uh you know I'm not going to go
to Geneva and talk some International
Committee in in in into making
nomenclature I wish I could do that
sometime because they come up with a lot
of really stupid things I mean why do
they have a why is a yada by bigger than
a zettabyte right but but um uh I mean
you could you think they at least when
they get up to the end of the thing they
would go in alphabetical order but but
um uh but uh uh you know uh so so these
standards uh it might never happen that
the whole world switches over to aspects
but it's so much better than anything
out there I'm hoping that you know by by
making this lecture now and if all you
guys tell a friend you know two friends
and each each of them two friends then
you know in Five Years everybody will
know what aspects of a graph are uh but
one thing I can be sure is uh whatever
they're called uh you know Rose by Any
Other Name
as you'll see uh uh soon the uh aspects
are are are are terrific Okay so
now um
here's a typical graph on five vertices
and what the aspects of it are it has
five aspects and it turned out to be
zero one one three and five
I usually list them in increasing order
but that's uh you know they're always
non-negative uh for an undirected graph
uh
here's uh
C5 this is the five cycle uh it's
aspects uh turn out to be uh well zero
is always one of the aspects by the way
um uh that's that's obvious because uh
you know there's it's always multiple of
X there's there's never a constant term
on this thing that's determining to zero
uh so put x equals zero you always get
zero so uh
so so the aspects here are zero three
minus golden ratio
three minus golden ratio two plus golden
ratio and two plus golden ratio well
sorry two plus gold Invasion it's nice
golden ratio you know so the point what
1.6 so this is about 1.4
uh so you know they aren't always
integers you don't have you can you know
if there were always integers that would
be really beautiful that would be really
great but that just you know doesn't
work that way uh here's another
sort of random graph on five vertices
just to give you an example of what
happened and and and there is a there's
an atlas of graphs where where all the
small graphs it'll uh it lists all their
aspects
but but it usually gives them
numerically rather than in in symbols
okay so here you are now
um
uh
main thing is now we Define what aspects
are let's calculate with them let's
let's see all kind of things that that
they do and one one of the things we
already know is that the number of
spanning trees okay the aspects
um are zero or Alpha zero is zero and
then the other ones uh up to n minus one
uh the number of spanning trees
is
class
the Alpha One Alpha two alpha n minus
one divided by n
okay that's the coefficient of x uh yeah
because it's you know because we have x
times x minus Alpha One times x minus
alpha n minus 1 that's the
characteristic polynomial okay so so one
of the things about aspects is that they
tell you how many spanning trees there
are
now
um
uh suppose I know uh the aspects of the
graph I'd like to now figure out the
aspects of the complement of the graph
the complement of a graph is defined is
you say that two edges are adjacent in
the complement if they're not if and
only if they're not adjacent in in the
graph itself
uh you know two two different edges and
so uh
for example
um
uh take this strange graph I had here
I'll call this a g
um
and uh and C of G was 2 minus one minus
one zero zero two four one one you see
that vertex three here is the connected
to all to everything else
um
one is connected to two and three
and four is connected to three
and five is connected to three that's
that's it okay now what about C of G bar
um uh so uh this is two zero zero minus
one you see I wherever I have a zero
here I change that to a minus one
so I get a zero minus one minus one
there and I get zeros here
and I get minus one minus one
minus one zero minus one
with me I'm just complimenting uh where
I had a zero it's none zero so then I
have to add up here I got two here I get
zero here I get um three whoops I I a
little typo there
um
okay so so here's the C of G bar right
now
um
uh
I am
I think I have time to
I I think I have time to prove to prove
one one uh one result so that you get
the idea of of of how these uh uh how
these Matrix teams are proved so anyway
if you look at uh at c plus c bar this
you know
um uh add add these to this what do you
get it's four minus one minus one minus
one minus one you get fours on the
diagonal and you get minus one
everywhere else okay so so this is the
this is uh
sorry C of G plus C of G bar
and it's equal to C of K five or you
know the the complete graph and it's
equal in this case to 5i minus J
where I is the identity Matrix and J is
the Matrix of all ones
okay so I is equal to
The Matrix one one one one one and zeros
everywhere else
and J is the Matrix one everything all
ones
right so I I take 5i minus J I get 4 on
the diagonal and I get minus 1
everywhere else okay
so now what I'm going to do is I'm going
to I'm going to tell you if you know the
ad how how to figure out the aspects of
G bar if you know the aspects of G
and
it re it requires a little calculation
but I'm going to do it uh and and for
those of you who
don't who understand matrices
determinants you'll see if otherwise it
won't take long so so so so I say let's
C be any Matrix
um
um whose rows sum to zero
uh the rose sum add up every row and you
get zero then I'm going to write down a
formula for the determinant of x i plus
y j minus z c where X Y and Z are
arbitrary numbers I'm going to give you
a nice formula for this determinant
so what's this what's the uh I'm going
to do I'm going to work it in the case n
equals three and my this will be
completely General so that you'll
understand what would happen if n was
equal to a billion uh so this is the
Matrix when n equals three The Matrix
looks like this X Plus y minus Z C11
y minus z c 1 2 y minus z c one three
okay the the the diagonal entries are
always
X Plus y minus Z times c times
C sub I I I and the other the off
diagonal ones are uh Z this will be z c
two one z c three one so on
um okay Z see one two three so so here's
the here's the The Matrix
um and I want to calculate the
determinant one okay I want to simplify
it so I add columns two and three to cut
to column one
uh that gives me
um well these these uh columns two and
three don't don't don't change
but I'm going to add them to column one
I'm sorry dc322
um
X Plus y minus EC okay so add it to
column one what what happens uh I get X
Plus 3y
and then minus c z times C11 plus c one
two c one three but that's zero
I I said that the row of sum sum to zero
so so I get X plus three y
everywhere in that first column
yeah I added comms two and three to
column one okay so now I now I'm going
to factor that out X Plus 3y
actually I'm going to factor out X Plus
3y over X
and and that's going to and then I'm
going to get X here
and I'm going to have the same
um you know and then I'm going to have y
y minus
I'll keep these so so first of all I
factor out x minus 3y over X and so I
get X here instead and now I'm gonna I'm
gonna subtract y over x times this from
from these two and I'm going to get Z
minus z c 1 2 x minus
z c 2 2 and minus z c three two here and
I'm going to get minus z c one three
minus z c 2 3 and x minus z33 I I I got
rid of the Y's here by by uh subtracting
y over x times the First Column from the
second column then I subtracted y over x
times that doesn't change the value of
the determinant
but um so now I you know I got rid of
the the Y's have disappeared from this
this equation so we're making some
progress now I I subtract now I go back
and I again I I subtract these two from
the first one before I added them so so
now I subtract com 2 from 1 column three
from one and I and what I'm what I when
I get here is x minus z c one one uh
actually and minus
z21 minus Z
c three one
um and and these and these other two
columns stay the same uh and so what I
what I what I have proved uh by this by
this derivation is the following
uh I I wound up with X Plus n y over x
times the determinant of x i minus z c
all this derivation I got rid of the you
know I started with this guy
and and I wound up with with a matrix
that has x's on the diagonal and minus z
c uh there okay so uh and so this is
also equal to X Plus NY over times Z to
the N times the determinant of
X over z i minus C for example all right
now this this little theorem uh is going
to tell me then uh how to calculate the
aspects of the complement of a graph the
reason is
we have observed that c of G bar is
equal to ni minus J minus C of G
so the determinant of the characteristic
polynomial of this thing
is the determinant of the x i minus C of
G bar
which is the determinant of x minus n
times I plus J plus C of G
now I plug into my general formula for
evaluating all of determinants of this
form I and I know how to do it and and
and
you can check it out what do you get it
turns out that this this turns out to be
equal to x times x minus n plus alpha 1
through x minus n
plus alpha n minus 1. and so therefore
the aspects of G bar
of g equals zero Alpha One alpha n minus
1 imply aspects of
of G bar are zero n minus alpha n minus
one
n minus Alpha One
just I I'm writing on an increasing
order again
um so uh uh
for example
um
I take C5
remember C5 is this um
is this graph one two three four five in
it and its aspects were zero uh two uh
I'm sorry three minus Phi three minus V
two plus Phi and two plus v these were
the aspects of the uh of the five cycle
uh what about C5 what are the aspects of
the complement so C5 bar
the aspects are five minus this this is
three it turned out the same thing and
the reason is that c that the five cycle
is also its complement the the
complement of C5 is one three five two
four I mean it's just it it it it it
turns out that this is a self complement
itself complementary graph and so
naturally its aspects are are
symmetrical and
um in that way uh
uh remember we had the aspects of the
complete graph
um
K4 I had that way back here remember
there were zero four four and four
Okay now what's the complement of the
complete graph
it's the empty graph no edges right now
what are the aspects of the empty graph
zero zero zero zero zero all right it
all checks out this is the complement of
the empty graph okay now um
but I do want to um
show you now
uh
how we how how we how how we March along
and develop uh the theory of aspects uh
more and
and so I want to talk about
the direct sum of graphs
uh which is a very very trivial way to
get one graph from another
uh of G and H so so so uh uh authors
don't agree on on notation but this one
is is beginning to win I have I have
bobi's help on this uh G plus h direct
sum just means take take G and take H
and put them next to each other and and
you got the direct sum of graphs so for
example if G is
is of C5 and H is is equal to
um uh our two-dimensional Cube or C4
uh then um G direct sum H is is the
following graph on nine vertices
looks like this
okay direct sum of graph pretty easy but
what's what are the aspects of the
direct sum of the graph okay well uh
take a look at the laplacian uh so we
got uh you know I got uh the the five
cycle here
um
uh and uh uh what I'm sorry
uh and and zeros here and then H the
other vertices the other four vertices
are make a four cycle so that's this guy
um
so what what you do is you just you know
it um the Sea of
in other words uh C of G of the direct
sum of H is is the direct sum of of C of
G and and C of H this is called the
direct sum of two matrices if you if you
take take one Matrix and then you put
the other one up and you put zeros in
between okay so uh
the aspects then are
uh so G has uh
aspects are
zero Alpha One
Alpha well you can call it Alpha you
know up to Alpha M minus one
and H aspects are beta 0 through beta so
n minus one uh aspects of of G direct
sum h r Alpha zero Alpha One
alpha n M minus 1 beta zero just you
just you just uh take the union of the
two you want to sort them into order you
can
uh so
that's that's really easy and um uh so
what are the aspects of of this graph on
nine vertices well zero zero three minus
Phi three minus Phi two two two plus
feet
two plus Phi and four because I got zero
two two and four from from H and I get
you know the others from G so these are
the aspects notice there's two zeros now
right uh how the number of zeros is the
number of connected components of a
graph
so every every connected graph has just
one zero but if we put you know the
empty graph was all zeros and and and
the number of zeros number times aspect
to zeros that's the number of connected
components of a graph
okay now uh the interesting thing though
this was this was a trivial calculation
but now we can take the complement of a
direct sum
um and um
the compliment
of this graph you see what does that
look like well
um the complement of um
I could put a one two three four five on
it so okay so so I have one I'll redraw
it here
one two three four five
and uh six seven eight nine
uh uh now I take the complement of this
and it's
and and so that's one uh three
five
two four this is this is the complement
of the of the cycle
and the complement of of the of that is
six eight and uh seven nine
uh and then all the edges uh between
these two
so one is connected to six seven eight
nine two is connected to six seven eight
nine all you know that's the that's the
idea and and we call this the this is
this is G bar joined to h-bar so another
another thing you can you can do to two
graphs is instead of taking the direct
sum you can take their join which says
take G and take H and then everything
that that goes between them
and so what it turns out is
that the aspect
so so if I complement to get the join of
two graphs I I can complement uh G
complement H and take the comp here I
take the direct sum and complement that
and so I can apply my theorem that I
know about about taking ju taking uh
direct sums and compliments and I and I
get the formula for the aspects of of
the join of two graphs not the joint of
the uh and and the aspects are the
following uh zero
um M plus n
M plus beta 1
uh through M plus beta n minus one and N
plus alpha one through n plus alpha n
minus 1. so so if I have if I know the
aspects of G and aspects of H
I have a simple way to calculate the
aspects of their drawing which means
that that I I I've put all the
connecting things between them
um and um uh a quick example of that
earlier I I I showed you this this
particular graph
um and I said that it's aspects were
zero one one three five
now the in fact uh there's a simple
calculation that that you could do this
without evaluating any determinants
because this graph is equal to K1 joined
with K2 direct sum K2 bar
um
namely uh it's you take the one vertex
graph in the middle here and you join it
to the graph K2 which is which is this
times and K2 bar which which are these
two isolated vertices
okay so now you just you just apply the
formula that I had before
and you can figure out the aspects you
know the aspects of K2 are zero and uh
two aspects of K2 bar are zero and zero
uh so so that's the aspects of this guy
uh uh and the aspects of K1 is just zero
and so what I get is zero then M plus n
is five uh and then I have M plus beta
one so I'm going to get the zero one one
three
comes right out of that look of that
calculation so you can work that out
afterwards okay now we're running short
on time so I want to get to the
to the to the uh uh to want to to one
more beautiful thing and that is what
about the what about G Square h
so that's another nice way to combine
two graphs uh this is their direct sum
I'm a direct product uh we've got
different names but uh and it's it's got
it's so important in operation that it
has uh many many different notations but
this is the only notation that hasn't
been uh corrupted to something else well
all the other notations turn out to be
uh uh you know some people use
uh
well they've written 10 papers and they
use different notation each paper so so
so but this one is winning now so so so
so let me let me explain what this
operation is on Two on Two graphs and
and so if I take G is is C5 and H is C4
again what what you do is you uh I you
make copies of of G uh like in this case
four copies of G
so I have 20 vertices in all if there
were five vertices in G and four and H
and then I and then I join uh uh
corresponding things in in the different
ones uh if they were if there were
Neighbors in age so
you know so uh these will
these will go
like this and there will be five five
things coming over here and five things
coming down here and five things coming
down here but nothing going across here
because look because those aren't
adjacent H so so that's the idea of a of
G uh uh direct sum what is it called I
remember I forgot the name of this kind
of thing
um
so um if if you if you get this for
Christmas
um uh you you look at page um Cartesian
product there we go
Cartesian product of of two vertices so
here's here's the you know the direct
sum we got the join got the Cartesian
product there's there's a bunch of other
nice products there's here's the direct
product or the conjunction of two things
there's a strong product there's an odd
product there's a lexicographic product
um and these are all uh associative
operations and all arise in lots of
applications
and if you turn to uh
exercise
uh it turns out it tell that there are
nice ways to calculate the aspect
of of all of these things uh if you know
the aspects of G and H or in this case
it's G Prime and g double Prime
um and also uh the if you want to get
the line graph of the graph that's
another
thing so so all of these calculational
aspects uh work I'm gonna I'm talking
about Part D here the Cartesian product
of of two graphs and
um the um we're short of time but uh the
uh
the the form for the laplacian Matrix is
actually not too hard to understand uh
and we saw an example of it when I drew
when I drew this when I drew this here
uh I I had sort of uh this looks like um
uh P2 Cartesian product with P2 here and
this is here so then I uh
the the essentially
um
you know you you take you take C of G
and write it right on the diagonal and
then and then you add minus ones
according to uh
uh I'm sorry the
um
there would be only twos there then you
then then you take the um uh C of H but
you but but the actual formula is um I I
Cross C of H
plus C of G
cross I
um this is an M dimensional kind of
thing this n-dimensional uh this is
called the the
um uh the chronicle product or or
Cartesian product of of matrices and uh
so
this is what C of g h is and
and Chronicle product of matrices has
lots of nice uh determinate formulas
that make it easy to calculate it so
what it turns out are the aspects of G
and H are
uh the sum Alpha zero plus beta zero
Alpha zero plus beta Juan and so on
uh you know it's all all the alpha I
plus beta J
um are the aspects of the Cartesian
product of two graphs
therefore
for
um
we can see why I got the aspects here
zero two two two two two four four six
because I started out uh we start out
with P2 it's it's just a same as K2 it's
the aspects are zero and two this is P2
then P2
um star P2 uh I I I I take zero plus
zero zero plus two two plus zero two
plus two
and then
to get to the cube in three dimensions
uh I I take zero plus zero two plus you
know zero plus two and so on I had zero
and and then I add two to everything
um so I get
um
I get this right now we'll do one more
and and then you you'll see
what's happening this is the four
dimensions or here's your hypercube this
is graph on 16 vertices what are its
aspects
how many twos I I I'm gonna get the four
twos
six six fours
uh four sixes and one eight so it's
gonna turn out just you know you just uh
take all of these guys and then add two
to them all
also and this is what you get so um
uh in general you see what what's
happening here this is
for guys this is six guys this is four
guys this is this is the one here this
one is the binomial coefficient so this
is four choose uh one four choose two
four choose three four choose four
now and so how many uh how many spanning
trees does the uh does this hyper cube
have uh well two to the fourth times
four
to the sixth times six to the fourth
times eight to the one
divided by
16.
okay but this uh in general we're
getting two to the
you know a d dimensional hypercube so D
choose one four uh D two two uh and so
on till we get finally to 2D
to the D choose d
uh divided by 2 to the D
expanding trees of a d dimensional Cube
all right well I'm let's just uh uh
I mean because these are the aspects of
of the n-dimensional hypercube and so uh
I can take out a factor of a take out
factor of two here
there's how many
the sum of all these binomial
coefficients is two to the
D minus one so it's two two to the 2 to
the D minus 1 times 1 to the D plus D1
2 to the D choose two up to D to the D
two's D and then I divide by 2 to the D
so I subtract d
so here's a glorious formula
for the number of
of
Spanish trees
um
of a d dimensional Cube and that is what
I promised to teach you today I mean in
in the abstract of this stuff all right
well
so I'm about ready to wrap up but the
but but coming back to the beginning you
remember we were talking about directed
graphs not just undirected graphs this
whole theory of aspect supplies also to
directed graphs but hardly anybody has
talked about it because they were
worried about it because because the
aspects of a directed graph
are complex numbers uh in general they
aren't real and uh I don't know that
seems scary or something I don't know
but all of these things still work you
can Define the Cartesian product that
directed graphs the you know the
complement of directed graphs the uh the
the the the arc directed graph of the uh
you know the these other these other
forms of products that I that they
talked about
um they work on directed graphs too and
uh even more
besides the join you can have a directed
join where you have G Arrow H which says
you take it you take a directed graph G
and direct the graph H and then you then
you also have a line going from every
vertex of G to every vertex of H and you
can calculate the aspects of all these
of all these things and therefore you
can calculate the number of
directed uh you know the oriented
spanning trees
the formula
when you divide by n you're not getting
the um
it's a little different in the directed
case because because uh as we saw
sometimes there's more spanning trees
that have one as a root than than have
two as a root but what it when you
divide by n what you're getting is the
average number of spanning trees
averaged over all possible routes
but but all the formulas then go go
through
um and uh and and the aspects of of an
oriented cycle turn out to be zero and
one minus
Omega 1 minus Omega squared through one
minus Omega
to the N minus 1. the oriented cycle
where Omega is a nth root of unity
complex number and and and so then you
can you can consider oriented Cycles uh
you know with Cartesian products and you
get lots and lots of of uh very nice
results about exactly how many oriented
spanning trees they have and so on
okay I'm done with any questions
huh
do the aspects help this remind the
graph uniquely in certain ways yeah
that's that's uh a natural question uh
can can different graphs uh uh have have
the same aspects the answer is yes they
can uh so but but it's pretty good way
for sorting so so if you you know uh so
a lot of times you can determine you you
can determine that graphs are not
isomorphic because they don't have the
same aspect but uh but there are uh but
it was a conjecture for a while and then
you know but then somebody found I think
a graph of 13 vertices that you know the
two of them had the same aspects and
it's uh and it and these these
coincidences get uh aren't so rare after
you get the larger and larger graphs
um
the uh but it's it's it that's certainly
a natural question how how much does it
characterize it but then you know what
happens to if you take a graph and you
add one Edge to it what how do aspects
change you know so you know so so there
there are uh they're they're just kind
of nice geometry here that because of
the of known themes about uh
uh about eigenvalues of matrices
yeah could do the whole um you could
construct a laplacian matrix for a
simplicial complex and not just just a
graph is there some similar
interpretation of the things I never
thought of that that would be that
that's that's a really cool idea in
other words uh
try to consider hypergraphs instead of
yeah okay
um uh
I I bet there is maybe next Christmas we
talk about it yeah
okay so Merry Christmas to all and
remember there's all these freebies
sitting out here
okay